[Music]  a weird war  we don't know his name money weapons  Intel he's planning something Sergeant  McDonald welcome to the city of souls  there are few here to uphold the law and  many of those who resist corruption  disappear  terrorism is good for business  as long as there is a war on terrorists  there will be no real War on Drugs  we've got bigger problems  we're not one for one and lost for keros  we're a team I want to know how many  they have and where they intend to use  them  y'all got a clear picture all set these  things take planning and preparation  these things take violence and timing  [Music]  I can do both  you're the commander of a foreign Terror  organization  I can say the same to you  digitally pre-order Call of Duty Modern  Warfare 2 and play the campaign up to a  week early